perhaps you're thinking of purchasing a
hybrid or plug-in electric vehicle after
all you care about the environment and
this seems a good way to help but are
you really helping the environment to
answer this question you must first
answer a question of your own what kind
of driving do you do if you drive in
heavy city traffic a hybrid or plug-in
electric vehicle could cut your
greenhouse gas emissions in half while
saving you money over the vehicles life
but if you spend most of your time
cruising on the highway hybrid and
plug-in electric vehicles offer little
environmental benefit they just cost
more so before you buy consider how you
drive and for those of you considering
going fully green with a plug-in
electric vehicle you should know that
gasoline hybrids are often the cleaner
option today this might change in the
future however as we switch to cleaner
sources of electricity like wind power
at Carnegie Mellon University's Scott
Institute for energy innovation
we're helping policy makers and
consumers make wise decisions based on
scientific and technical information you
can help
you